- [Interviewer] All right, Monty?
- Yes.
- Monty, where are you from?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from Spain.
- You're from Spain?
- Yeah.
- You came to, the United
States at what age?
- About six months maybe less.
- Just when you were very young--
- Yeah, I was raised in Los Angeles.
- In Los Angeles, okay.
And you had both your parents?
- Well, they're deceased now.
- Yeah, but growing up
you had both your, uh?
- Yeah, we started out as a family
you know, but, things happened.
- Yes.
Did your parents separate at some point?
- Well, my father died when I was two.
- Oh my God!
- Pneumonia.
He had a one lung left.
- Oh my God!
So, did your mom remarry or?
- She remarried.
(motorcycle engine roaring)
Unfortunately, the wrong persons for her,
but, she has about two
or three more husbands.
- And so, how was you childhood?
- It was very religious.
I went to a Catholic
school for eight years.
- Oh, really!
- It's not there now,
but, it was for the first to eighth grade.
- And your childhood was good,
no abuse, anything like that?
- Well, there was some abuse over there.
They were run mostly by nuns
and one nun in the fifth
grade, she was the worst.
It was a physical abuse actually.
Yeah, she would slap the pupils
that didn't learn fast enough
(mumbles) or make him sit
at the edge of a desk.
You know, punishment like that.
- Right.
- I didn't like it.
That was the only thing I
didn't like about the school.
Was the strict nuns.
- So later on, did you go to college?
- I went to Santa Monica City College.
- Okay, and where'd you go--
- Didn't graduate though.
Just had a couple of semesters.
- And how was your work, career,
Are you still working?
- Yes, as a matter of fact, I am.
Just temporarily.
- Okay.
What did you do throughout
your career for jobs?
- Well, I went to the ranches
to learn how to ride a horse, yeah.
And, from there I went to a ranch
owned by somebody from Arizona, a cowboy.
He raised horses there
then he trained them
and got them ready to go to the racetrack.
So, I got paid 25 a month
and room on board though
and there was 15 of us.
- Oh!
- Everybody had their own room
and, they worked throughout
the ranch, training the horses.
And when they got ready,
the trainer at the ranch would
send them to his racetrack.
- What other jobs did you have later on?
- I drove a bus for the RTD,
at the time it was called RTD
and I was there about
three years, you know.
After that I went to Texas for a year,
and worked, in the...
I was the second cook.
In other words, I did all the baking.
- Okay.
- You know,
and they were grooming
me to be a first cook.
And I was looking forward
to that 'cause I like food.
But, it didn't work out cause
I had to come back here.
My girlfriend was..
Had trouble with her baby,
had meningitis or something, I don't know.
Anyways, they needed me
back here so, I left.
- So, today you're working as a--
- I clean apartments.
- You clean apartments?
- Yeah.
Temporarily.
- Okay, but it's money?
- It helps pay the bills
- yes.
- And the women.
- So, you're married?
- Yes.
- How many years have you been married?
- Five years.
- Five years?
- Yeah.
- And how old are you?
- Me?
- Yes.
- Can you keep it secret?
- I can.
- You can, can, can't?
- Well, I think if you'd rather not say
I won't pressure you to tell me your age.
- No, you would be surprised.
- I mean you look healthy.
Your hair's gray.
- I'm not really healthy.
I'm not 100% in good health
but, I'm hanging in there, you know.
I took a lot of drugs in my younger years.
- Oh, you did?
- Yeah.
Sorry about that.
But I now recognize them as a poison,
when I see other people do it.
- Are you using alcohol or drugs today?
- No, I'm not.
- Not at all?
- No.
- And do you have children?
- As a matter of fact, I don't.
- No children?
- No.
- And you were married how many times?
- I got married twice.
- Twice?
And what happened to your first marriage?
How did that (mumbles)
- It was actually a shotgun wedding.
- What do you mean?
- Well, I got this girl pregnant
and she told her mom and
her mom threatened me.
So I had to marry her just
to give the kids the name.
- Got it.
So today you like to come down to Skid Row
and pick up some of the
ladies that work here?
- Yeah, I do.
You know, I look at it as
I'm doing myself a favor
and them a favor, you know.
Sorry about that, that's
the way I am right now.
It's the oldest what in the world?
- Obviously yeah.
It's an old profession--
- Profession.
- So you'll come down how often?
- Well, three times a week.
- Three times a week?
- And you'll go to your car
or you'll go to a hotel or where'd you go?
- It depends.
Most of the time I'll go to a small hotel.
- Yeah, there's a lot
of cheap hotels nearby?
- Yeah.
There's a favorite I like
is called, oh, well, no.
- It's okay, you don't need to.
- Yeah, and I know the manager there
through the drug train, you know.
So, that's how I get a break.
- Yeah.
And have you had any bad experiences?
Some of the girls well will kinda
trick the guys and Rob
them and some of the guys
will beat the women sometimes,
I've heard both sides
of the--
- A couple of them have
stolen from me, you know.
When I was in the restroom
or something, you know.
I come off, they're gone.
- Yeah, and so is your wallet.
- My wallet's gone.
- Yeah.
- I learned my lesson though.
And does your wife know that you do this?
- She suspects, she suspects
but I don't come out and tell her.
I'll just, you know,
I'll let her suspect until
she catches me in the act.
I just gotta let her guess.
- I'm going to post this video
on YouTube and there's a chance your wife
or a friend of your wife might see this.
How do you feel about that?
- She would forgive me.
She's not gonna go read more into it
and to what I tell her, you know.
There's nothing really going
on, it's perfectly fine.
You know.
- So she'll believe that--
- This will be perfectly fine
'cause I'm getting cash
- you are?
- And I'm gonna buy her a nice steak
or whatever, you know.
- Do you see it as something that you just
kinda have to do to remain
happy and levelheaded?
- What, the sex?
- Yeah.
- It satisfies me, yes it does.
I've been this way since I was growing up.
You know, there's
something inside of a man
that makes him want to go after a woman.
I don't know, I forgot what you call it,
but I have a lot of it
ever since I was small.
And to this day I still, you know,
it hasn't left me yet.
- Right.
It's a blessing and a curse.
- Yeah, truth.
- So what kind of relationships
do you have with these women,
is it purely just you have
sex or is it sometimes--
- Well they know what I want
and, you know,
and I know what they offer.
So, most of them are repeats
and that helps a lot cause I don't like to
start off from scratch.
- Yeah.
So you establish some kind of trust?
- Yeah, right.
Trust goes a long way.
- Yes it does.
Do you use condoms?
Are you safe when you have--
- I use condoms, yeah.
- Yeah, I think that's important.
- I don't particularly like them,
but, it's safety reasons.
- Yeah.
- When I was growing
up my first intercourse
was with a Jewish lady.
She was downstairs at a
Barney's store downstairs
and I was in the store and the clerk says,
"Hey Monty, you wanna give her
a hand with those groceries?"
I said, "Sure."
So it was apartment right above the store.
We went up to the store and--
- How old were you?
- 14.
- 14?
- Or 13.
- Yeah.
And by the way, she says,
"Help me with the box, put it up here."
So I helped her and that's how it started.
We ended up in her bed.
- How old was she?
- Probably 38, four--
- And here you are, many decades later.
You're still at it?
- My first, I still remember that, yeah.
- Yeah, first time is
always memorable, right?
- And I went there later
'cause the neighborhood
kinda got wind of it.
I went up there and there
was five or six guys up there
you know, drinking and stuff like that.
And she was in bed, you know,
and then I heard say,
"I want all money on Monty, I want you"
you know, and (murmurs) wanna
stick around her, you know?
You know, I like my privacy.
- Yes.
- So, I didn't even talk
to her, I just took off.
But, she was married a woman
to an elderly or something.
They both worked in a hospital.
And that's how I got to
know her, my first one.
- I think maybe this is more common than
people realize, how many
times people will stray.
- Probably so, yeah.
- Yeah.
I mean, do you find it helps
to keep your marriage together?
- What, that thing,
you mean this marriage?
- For you, I mean,
you're currently married
and having these all things on the side.
- Yeah, well I bet you
I've always liked that
and as long as I could do it, yeah.
And long as she doesn't find out
and, you know, make a big deal about it.
Yeah, I'm comfortable with it.
Like I said, she was a
stranger to me, right?
And a lot of these people
I meet around here,
they start out as strangers too.
- Yes
- yeah.
- Yeah, and lot of the girls
are actually very nice, right?
You get to know them and they're--
- I only deal with nice people.
- All right Monty, well thank you so much
for being so open and sharing your story.
- Okay, well, thank you too, also.
- Thank you.
- Good luck to you.
- Okay.